well my friends a Texas woman has been
charged with murder for what authorities
are calling a self-induced abortion this
is sadly completely predictable based on
what Texas has been doing as far as
abortion law for years now and really
for decades now in terms of what they've
been trying to do and one of the lines
that's repeated so often that it's like
cliche we've all heard it so many times
it's a cliche at this point is Banning
abortion doesn't reduce abortions it
just reduces legal abortions in your
particular State what does that mean
well it means if you make abortion more
difficult to obtain or you make it
illegal you make it illegal in more
situations people will either go to a
neighboring state if they can afford it
and if it's legal in a neighboring state
or they will pay for an illegal abortion
this is very common in other countries I
mean if you if you look at where I was
born Argentina there were long periods
of time where it was illegal but if you
had money you just went to a private
doctor and it was fine and you you had
the money to do it that's the second
option third option what we sometimes
call a back alley abortion a home
abortion in this case it's being called
a self-induced abortion and that is
exactly what happened here with 26 year
26 year old lizelle Herrera who was
arrested late last week and has been
charged with murder Herrera was given a
500
000 Bond five half a million dollars we
are talking about here now remember that
this idea of I don't know do we punish
the women this is something Republicans
have been toying with for a long time
they've tended to go against it but
remember that when Donald Trump ran
Trump who Trump is pro-choice Trump was
pro-choice for 68 years then he ran for
president as a Republican and he had to
have some kind of credible escape hatch
to explain suddenly I'm against abortion
he's speaking at the March for Life the
Story Trump told us completely
unbelievable story
was that despite being in favor of
choice for 68 years
he met a kid whose mom said I thought
about getting an abortion and Trump was
like I like that kid
it would have been sad if that kid
didn't exist so now I'm the strongest
pro-life can I mean it was nobody
believed it and a result of trump not
actually being pro-life was that he
stepped into some controversial
territory like when he said well you've
got to punish the woman remember this do
you believe in punishment for abortion
yes or no as a principle the answer is
that
there has to be some form of punishment
for the woman yeah it has to be some
form 10 cents 10 years that I don't
right so the next day Trump walked it
back but the punishment for back alley
or home abortions that they seem fine
with and we have other instances of
similar situations you might remember
back in October just a few months ago
six seven months ago uh
yeah seven months ago we covered the
story I think on the bonus show of a
Native American woman in Oklahoma who
was convicted of manslaughter over a
miscarriage this was Brittany Pula 21
years old convicted on second-degree
manslaughter by a Comanche County jury
for the death of her fetus with a
gestational age of 15 to 17 weeks so
don't be confused about the big picture
of how Texas has dealt with abortion the
number of abortion clinics in Texas has
declined dramatically you go back to the
mid-1980s and we're putting a chart up
on the screen for our viewers over 120
clinics at which abortion Services were
available that is now under 20 as of a
few years ago it may be even lower now I
didn't have updated data so people
really may have no idea what we're in
for here if Republicans get their way
and this is really about two things it's
actually it's really about three things
number one this is about on paper
reducing the number of abortions in
Texas now remember you're not actually
reducing the number of abortions you
might reduce the number of legal
abortions in Texas because people will
either be pushed to other states if they
can afford it or they will be pushed
into you know so-called private back
alley home abortions that's number one
number two this continues to be about
controlling women's bodies in a way that
lines up with the stated morals of the
people doing it and it's important to
include the way the word stated morals
because as we have found out through the
election of trump with Evangelical
support despite his Affairs and all
these we know that they're only their
stated morals it's not their morals
they're their morals that they use to
try to get themselves elected and then
number three it's also a real sign about
what might be coming at the Supreme
Court level within months the Supreme
Court one of the most right-wing Supreme
Courts we've had in decades is going to
make a decision that might change the
established precedent of Roe v Wade
making abortion legal in the country
generally speaking without placing an
undue burden on women that uh framework
that precedent may be reversed in just
months by the current Supreme Court the
states are pushing it because this has
always been the plan when they get a
more conservative Supreme Court they all
start doing at Mississippi Texas
Missouri many states have been pushing
and passing similar bills knowing that
they're going to be fought they're going
to be appealed hopefully they go to the
Supreme Court and the Supreme Court will
issue what could be a life-changing
ruling for so many women and families
around the country is it time to move
out of Texas well I don't know
a part of it is a question of what does
the Supreme Court decide and we're going
to know that soon but this is exactly
what we predicted they would do they are
doing it and you can look at any one of
these cases and say well but in this
particular case or in that particular
this was the plan all along we knew that
they were going to do it and they're
going to continue
um this is uh this is kind of funny Fox
News and other right-wing media have
gone silent on Ivermectin one of the
popular
promoted quote treatments for covid that
many on the right wing media have
promoted instead of vaccination have
promoted as a reason why we don't really
need to take precautions very early
before there was any evidence they said
Ivermectin works and now that we have
multiple studies that shows Ivermectin
doesn't work for covid for covid some
people miss that they go David it works
fine for horse deworming or for
parasitic infections
does it work for covid no
Fox News hasn't issued an apology
as far as I know uh Rogan and others
haven't issued apologies
they just aren't talking about
Ivermectin anymore so let's go back a
little bit early in the pandemic I was
right there in the Forefront I think it
was it was March of 2020 if not April of
2020 and I came to you and I said hey
here's a bunch of stuff that is being
looked at and it should be looked at
there's this thing called
hydroxychloroquine should be looked at
it's being tested
um there is Azithromycin does it have a
possible antiviral effect it's going to
be studied we should study it a
combination of I believe it was HIV
drugs that were being looked at what
about taking the z-pack with zinc or
with vitamin D and I said to you there's
eight to twelve different things we
don't know if they work for covid they
should be studied they are being studied
and different right-wing media fixated
on one or two of them and said this just
works we have a treatment this works
open everything early they fixated on
hydroxychloroquine event actually it
became a focus on Ivermectin today we
know Ivermectin doesn't work for covid
right-wing media touted it for months
and months and months they were
convinced that it works convinced that
there was a cover-up because it's cheap
and they don't want you to they don't
want you to know they used Ivermectin
promotion to cast out on the vaccine
while pushing something unproven you
even even had people saying the vaccine
is deadly Alex Berenson said it Tucker
Carlson said on his show it seems that
thousands tens of thousands of people
may have died from the vaccine I mean
really crazy dangerous stuff while
promoting Ivermectin and claiming they
don't want you to know about it and they
don't want you to have it we now know it
doesn't work okay and yet Fox hosts
pushed anecdote anecdote after anecdote
after anecdote and in fact mediaite has
a great sample of them in January of
last year
Laura Ingram said a friend of hers took
Ivermectin after getting covered and she
got better now what's the problem with
that it's the same problem that exists
with a lot of homeopathic treatments
which is a lot of things get better
without doing anything for example
headaches
wow you know I uh I had a terrible
headache and then I ate a papaya with
peanut butter and the next day I felt
better well yeah most people's headaches
get better
and it's the same thing with covet most
people get better from covid I could say
you know I uh
I had covid and I decided to burn a
bunch of tennis balls sprinkle cinnamon
on it and breathe the fumes and within
five days I was better of covid this is
not how we study stuff particularly when
you expect the regression to demean you
you expect that most people are going to
get better okay in September Brian
kilmead suggested Ivermectin could treat
covid saying sometimes drugs work for
different things yeah off-label uses are
a thing there was just no evidence
Ivermectin worked for covet in December
Ben Carson said Ivermectin is effective
against covet there was no such evidence
two weeks later Tucker Carlson
interviewed a psychiatrist who said
Ivermectin could be a lifesaver now my
dad's a psychiatrist he would not go
around telling you what works to treat
covid because that's not his area of
expertise
there were 300 or so such instances but
now we have the data from actual studies
we have a study called efficacy of
ivermectin treatment on disease
progression among adults with mild to
moderate covid-19 and comorbidities and
covet doesn't work oh I'm sorry
Ivermectin doesn't work for covet I wish
covet didn't work Ivermectin doesn't
work for covet and now Fox News and
other right-wing media are silent it's
just not a topic anymore like they've
talked about it 300 times and I don't
have any Clips to show you because there
are no clips they're not talking about
it anymore it's like they always do it
they just go silent this actually
happened with hydroxychloroquine just
think back we did a clip in April of
2020 called Trump and fox go silent on
hydroxychloroquine because studies came
out after a month of talking about
hydroxy saying it doesn't work for covet
so then they just never talked about it
again another example February fox goes
silent moment after massive jobs report
They promoted and predicted a bad jobs
report for days up until the jobs report
came out the jobs report was good Joe
Biden's President we don't talk about it
anymore the media literacy takeaway here
so there's a there's like a covid
takeaway which is the Ivermectin doesn't
work we now know that great
there's a media literacy takeaway as
well which is the power of what you
don't talk about this is the power of
story selection and power of the
exclusion of stories I'm not immune to
this like I'll give you an example
people email me they say David why
aren't you talking about Hunter Hunter
Biden's laptop that's right I'm not I
don't think it's a legitimate story to
cover and when I talk about it I talk
about it to tell you look at how crazy
the right is going about this but I'm
not covering Hunter Biden's laptop story
as a story I did it once I explained to
you all about the blind computer tech
who thinks it might be Hunter Biden's
lab you know the sort of I covered it
once I told you what's being said but I
do this too I ignore some stories
because I don't think that they are
stories everybody does this you just
have to understand whether it's being
done in good faith or in bad faith and
every time Fox News gets debunked about
whatever a jobs report
hydroxychloroquine Ivermectin you never
hear about it again
let me know your thoughts find me on
Twitter at dpacman and next Tuesday
April 19th we'll be doing the next David
packman show viewer Town Hall it will be
at 6 Eastern and it will be streaming on
the Pac-Man Live YouTube channel I want
to hear from as many of you as possible
that'll be Tuesday April 19th 6 p.m on
the Pac-Man Live YouTube channel quick
break right back
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
the David Patman show is of course a
viewer Community listener supported
program we depend on your support to do
what we do five days a week now for many
many years they tell me it's a big
number the folks do you can sign up and
support us by getting a membership at
joinpakman.com you can also now gift
memberships to others we have about 650
people who have requested a free
membership we will fulfill those
requests in the order that people gift
memberships there's a box that says this
is a gift when you check out at
joinpakman.com and we will give out
those free memberships in the order that
they come in you can of course always
use the coupon code wow 22 to Discount
your membership dramatically so much so
that people are telling me that's too
big a discount sir and I insist I say no
the people deserve it the people deserve
it join pacman.com is the place to sign
up hey this is um this is is really
really interesting because there's the
virus there's a viral video floating
around now of Senator Brian Schatz just
eviscerating Republican senator Josh
Hawley over his attempts to delay Joe
Biden's defense department nominees and
the video is great because of the
substance and because of the content but
the video is also great because it's a
reminder of the strategy that democrats
should be taking should be taking when
it comes to fighting Republicans and you
know remember when Michelle Obama said
when they go low we go high
and I've said many times before
we should not go down to their level of
lying and the
um uh just the these corrosive attacks
on Democracy in order to win like we we
shouldn't do that but when it comes to
rhetoric and style and tone and strategy
we absolutely need to be doing some of
the things that the right does because
otherwise we're just going to keep
losing so let's get to this video clip
in this video clip you are going to hear
uh Senator Schatz really just crushed
Josh Hawley who was by the way one of
the main pro-insurrection Senators let's
listen and then we'll discuss
he could have brought his floor charts
out here
and given a withering speech about what
all of the things that he thought went
wrong
but he's doing a very specific thing he
is damaging the Department of Defense we
have senior DOD leaders right we have
the armed services committee coming to
us and saying I don't know what to tell
him
I don't know how to satisfy him but he
is blocking the Staffing of the senior
leadership at the Department of Defense
and this comes from a guy who raised his
fist
in solidarity with the insurrectionists
true and this comes from a guy who
before the Russian invasion suggested
that maybe it would be wise for
zielinski
to make a few concessions about Ukraine
and their willingness to join NATO oh
boy this comes from a guy who just about
a month ago voted against Ukraine Aid
he's saying it's going too slow he voted
no
he voted no on Ukraine Aid and now he
has the gall to say it's going too slow
and this final insult is that until what
secretary Austin resigns
that's not a serious request
people used to come to me during the
Trump Administration all the time do you
think Trump should resign do you think
Tillerson should result that's a
I think all the people I disagree with
who quit their jobs and be replaced with
people I love of course I think they
should all resign that's not how this
world works that is not a reasonable
request from a United States Senator
that until the Secretary of Defense
quits his job I'm gonna block all of his
nominees that's preposterous and coming
from a person who exonerated Donald
Trump for extorting zielinski for
withholding lethal Aid
they withheld lethal Aid
until
unless
zielinski would release false smears
against Joe Biden's son and then he
voted to exonerate president Trump for
this and so spare me the new solidarity
with the ukrainians and with the Free
World because this man's record is
exactly the opposite
who could say that a single word of that
is wrong and of course Brian Schatz is
right and you know the stories you know
the Ukraine story you know the Josh
Hawley Insurrection story so this is
less about the facts that rant which is
not I mean listen it's a sound bite but
it's a two minute and 20 second sound
bite it's it's a for our
modern expectations that these things
need to be 20 seconds long to go viral
it's two minutes and 20 seconds long and
it's more substantive and it's still got
over 3 million views it might even be up
to four at this point so there is an
appetite for this type of attitude from
the Democratic party and this is the
attitude that the Democratic party needs
to take hone the anger and keep calling
out the worst of the worst for their BS
individually don't speak generally speak
individually Josh Hawley does a bad act
another humiliating part the word I'm
not gonna vote to approve anybody
confirm anybody to DOD
until Trump's Secretary of Defense
resigns Biden Secretary of Defense give
me a break that's absurd you're a
senator you're one of 100 you understand
how government works and it's absurd
that so many pretend that their supposed
concerns are genuine it's just nonsense
politically it's political nonsense and
so Democrats need to be making the
statements and I'm going to use the term
performing and I don't use that
pejoratively
Democrats are often right on substance
but they're not performing in the right
way and it doesn't get any attention
um there is enough fodder from
Republicans from what they are doing
from their hypocrisies and double
standards and absurdities for one of
these viral eviscerations of a
republican basically every day now you
do it every day it won't get as much
attention but certainly every week and
part of the issue is that Democrats
don't really have a media outlet that
approaches the power of Fox News I mean
you've got a 24 7 propaganda agenda
setting institution in Fox News and even
if only a few million people watch Fox
News at any one point in time their
agenda setting power is significant and
then you start seeing the same talking
points everywhere else this is sort of
what Rush Limbaugh created where he it
was the agenda setting power and so
Democrats end up trying to catch up and
on defense and a lot of people I know
are going to say but David what about
MSNBC MSNBC is a center-left corporate
media Network and it is not the other
side of the coin of Fox News it it's
just not it's not even close it's not
what it is and
um it needs to be said and repeated
endlessly unless the left starts doing
more stuff like this and this is just
one thing you might say but David this
won't change anyone's vote this might
change a few votes
but it's not going to be enough to
defeat Josh Hawley I don't even think
he's up for election maybe he is I don't
know if he's up this this time around
doesn't matter but the point is this is
the attitude that needs to be present
everywhere as a minimum it won't even
guarantee Victory but it's got to change
it's got to change because Democrats are
just not doing it in the right way a
Donald Trump did a rally over the
weekend in Selma North Carolina he was
swollen he was sweaty he was slurring
out of the gate he looked particularly
disheveled and he looked very confused
by the teleprompter which of course
Obama was bad for using a teleprompter
but Trump uses one all the time time the
crowd was strange and Trump seemed to be
kind of in a hurry he was rushing
through some of his teleprompter moments
uh didn't seem too thrilled to be there
he told incredibly corrosive lies and
I'm not going to play even a lot of
moments for you we're going to keep this
short just I think it's important to
keep a line on how the tone of these
changes but I'm not going to give you 15
Clips we'll just look at a few right
here Trump glitching all over the place
at one point he said that they have
something on PING I don't know what that
is maybe you know what it is listen to
this but look at this
movie and
anybody know what Ping is I does he mean
Bing the search engine that like nobody
uses is it on Bing
ping I don't even know what that means
and the entire speech was confused like
this it wasn't clear whether Trump was
misreading things off the prompter that
he shouldn't be using because it's bad
when Obama used the prompter it's bad
when Hillary used to prompter it's not
clear whether it was written incorrectly
on the prompter it's not clear if ping
means something that you and I just
don't know it's all very very strange
another moment where Trump seemed
visibly confused by the things he was
reading off the prompter he said that
one of the January 6th trials this is
almost comedic genius it ended in an
extortion and if you keep listening
it seems that what Trump means is that
it ended in an exoneration
I don't know why he called it an
extortion but there's almost like a
Freudian second layer meaning to it
listen to this
and as you probably have heard one of
the first January six trials ended
in an extortion and it was a horrible
thing what they were doing to people but
it was a horrible thing what they were
doing to people but and then I think
here he realizes he's not making any
sense there was exoneration
[Music]
because they effectively proved
that he got waved into the capital by
the police
remember this Nancy Pelosi was in charge
of
the capital you know that right and the
mayor of DC they were in charge of all
security now remember that Trump was
asked send in the National Guard to D.C
this is a semantic game that they're
talking about which as well the Speaker
of the House generally oversees Security
in the capital but of course the
problems started outside the capitol
they started outside the capitol when uh
crowd control barriers were breached and
Trump was asked call in please please
call in the National Guard and he didn't
do it so again confused did Trump mean
to say that it ended in an extortion
instead of an exoneration we don't know
we just never know none of it makes any
sense this was very interesting Trump
announced that he is endorsing Mehmet Oz
for senator from Pennsylvania uh now
we're going to go back to this
endorsement later because Maga world is
in meltdown mode because of this it's
very interesting but check out the
credentials that Trump touts for Mehmet
Oz here listen to this is see if you can
pick up on it
by the way I endorsed another person
today Dr
Oz
great guy a good man he's a good man
Harvard educated tremendous tremendous
career and they liked him for a long
time that's like a poll you know when
you're in television for 18 years that's
like a poll that means people like you
but he's a did you did you notice what
he did there he cites Harvard he goes
this is a Harvard educated doctor
as part of the reason why he's so
qualified but understand the hypocrisy
Harvard is woke leftist indoctrination
trash discriminating against Asian
students
except when they want to puff up Dr Oz
or Ted Cruz or did DeSantis go to
Harvard now I don't remember in that
case when their people went to Harvard
they go Harvard it's fantastic it's the
best it's such a implicit endorsement of
these people they went to Harvard except
then it's oh Harvard's trash Harvard's
gone woke Harvard is just liberal
indoctrination which is it guys oh right
it's whichever one is convenient to you
at the time at another very strange
moment Donald Trump said that he's the
cleanest and most honest human being
ever created by God this is slightly
hyperbolic yeah it's a bit of a delusion
of grandeur
I've got to be the cleanest Sheriff I
think I'm the most honest human being
perhaps that God ever created perhaps
instead of yeah a very very delusional
and then lastly Donald Trump has been
very careful not to actually say I'm
running in 2024 because he wants to
sidestep campaign Finance laws I also am
starting to think Trump may be laying
the groundwork for the health excuse for
2024. we'll talk about that tomorrow I
don't want to get into that today but
here is Trump basically getting as close
as he possibly can to saying he's
running without actually saying it 2024
most importantly we are going to take
back our beautiful beautiful beautiful
White House
2024 oh sorry play it's starting to play
again there so uh there are campaign
Finance reasons for which he for why he
might be doing that but also I am going
to tell you tomorrow about this new
health thing that Trump is introducing
I've never heard him do it before but he
did it in an interview with the
Washington Post late last week we'll
talk about that tomorrow if you listened
today and didn't see the clips I played
and you're curious how bad are the
Optics and they're very very bad you'll
be able to find all of these clips on
our Instagram at davidpackman show
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show so
sometimes I'll say kind of
metaphorically that uh Trump rallies and
Trump events are sort of like these
circus tent Evangelical churches but we
we don't literally mean that but Trump's
rally in Selma North Carolina over the
weekend actually really seemed like one
Madison cawthorne the radical republican
trumpist congressman who is in a
wheelchair he's paralyzed I guess it's
from the waist down from a car accident
he did a sort of re enactment of the
type of scene you would normally see
like in an Evangelical Faith healing
Church where he performed a miracle and
stood up using his arms holding himself
up on on a walker type thing with the
help of two people and and metal braces
on his on his legs I believe and this is
it's horrible on so many levels and I'm
going to talk about it so let's I'm
going to play the clip for you if you're
only listening what I'm gonna oh it's
important that I describe that what's
going on is he is performing a miracle
by standing despite being paralyzed from
the waist down just look at this 7
dollars a gallon
my friends this country can change very
quickly
and it may seem impossible people tell
me that it's impossible to change the
direction of our country that it's
impossible to root out the corruption in
our government
here he goes
[Applause]
[Music]
so they bring out a walker and then two
people kind of stand them up
this is a miracle that he's performing
and there is
well my friends God spared my life he
has given me the strength to stand
before you today so do not lecture me on
what is impossible
my fellow Patriots Americans are in the
business of doing the impossible because
With God all things are possible
yeah so listen first of all of course no
disrespect to his physical condition
whatsoever I wish he had never gotten
into that car accident I wish he had
full use of his legs of course of course
of course I would never ridicule anyone
for I mean he he has a terrible medical
condition it's horrible okay but what
are the issues here first of all
it's not like he stood up and walked
around and so even this framing of with
God anything is possible well why didn't
God keep you out of the accident
why didn't God give you the ability to
walk rather than just standing in this
way right I mean it's it's no disrespect
to him it's great that he can stand on
the strength of his arms that's a
beautiful thing that's better than not
being able to do it but why is it if
you're invoking that God did these
things why wouldn't God have spared you
from the accident or from the paralysis
or it just doesn't make any sense these
are indefeasible comments first of all
secondly
um FDR used to do this okay FDR
did this without Fanfare he didn't say
it's God's work FDR didn't weaponize his
physical problem to try to sucker people
into supporting anything in particular
FDR had actual policy ideas and that's
part of it it's sad that it works with
this crowd and
um it you know it's also not super
surprising that there's this palpable
lack of authentic spirituality that
pervades the Republican party it
performative charlatanism and that's
what we saw here from Madison cawthorne
you don't see this and go that is some
authentic spirituality you go that's
that's like the type of act you would
expect that a faith healing church and
it is classic cult stuff I may do a
deeper dive into this later this week or
next week there is a book called thought
reform and the psychology of totalism a
study of brainwashing in China it's
written by Robert J lifton this is a
fantastic book and it talks about the
different elements for brainwashing
people what is sometimes called thought
reform and one of the items on the list
is what's called mystical manipulation
the manipulation of experiences that
appear spontaneous but it's actually
planned and orchestrated by the group or
its leaders to demonstrate Divine
Authority spiritual advancement
exceptional Talent OR Insight that sets
the leader apart from humanity and
allows a reinterpretation of historical
events scripture and other experiences
that is exactly what Madison cawthorne
is doing here he's doing this mystical
manipulation where he's able to rise up
and stand despite being paralyzed
cawthorne also does number three number
three is a demand for Purity the world
is viewed as black and white everybody
is exhorted to conform to the ideology
of the group and to strive for
perspective Perfection and they use
guilt and shame to control people his
recent stuff with the orgies and the
cocaine he presents himself as he's pure
he's been told that the orgies and the
cocaine go on he doesn't participate in
it he's the pure one
um sacred science is another item from
the list of criteria for Thought reform
the group's Doctrine or ideology is
considered to be the ultimate truth
Beyond questioning and dispute truth is
not found outside the group The Leader
as the spokesperson for God or humanity
is likewise above criticism this is more
General to trumpism Trump literally has
said
you could don't believe what you're
seeing don't believe what you're hearing
I will tell you what's really going on I
will give you the truth
um and then lastly from this list
loading the language the group
interprets or uses words and phrases in
new ways so that often the outside world
doesn't understand
this includes thought terminating
cliches which serve to alter members
thought process to conform the group's
way of thinking they do that all the
time for example fake news that's a
thought-terminating cliche it's not it's
not really fake news it's just news you
disagree with it's reporting that's not
good for you that's fake news that's it
or hey you know what that was incredibly
insensitive and discriminatory what
you're oh you're woke
that's another thought terminating
cliche this is incredible how closely
their behavior conforms to these
brainwashing techniques and we will talk
about that more
speaking of brainwashing I am going to
show you the best moment I have ever
seen during interviews with Trump
supporters and Trump rally attendees
there is a video of a little kid brought
to this weekend's Trump rally in Selma
North Carolina
And the reporter asked the kid what are
you excited for and the kid goes I'm
excited to see Joe Biden oh and the mom
goes Trump
Trump now I have a few thoughts about
what might be going on here listen
closely to what the mom says this is the
best clip from a trump rally I have ever
seen how excited were you when you found
out there was gonna be a rally here
I'm just as excited as he was he's the
one that told me about it so yeah yeah
first rally yes sir I think they're more
excited than we are are you excited
what are you excited for
[Music]
um
[Laughter]
oh that is genius so okay so did you
guys notice
uh how
the mom kept saying it's the kids who
told us about the rally it's the kids
who are really the excited ones it's
almost like they're trying to say it's
like when you go to Disney World and
you're like look they wanted to come I
don't want to be here but they wanted to
come but maybe the kids have no idea
what's going on I mean the kid seems to
think he's at a Joe Biden rally so this
could be one of these things where
they're pushing their desire to be there
on to the kids and the kids have no
interest and they're just being dragged
in whatever it is it is one of the most
genius Clips I have ever seen from a
trump event here's another one this one
seems like a a parody two brothers say a
lot of really wacky stuff
seemed like every meeting I see is
undisgraceful
did you guys hear that it's not
disgraceful it's undisgraceful oh wow
that's pretty strong God and we support
you guys 100
and we just and we just want to tell the
fake news CNN MSNBC all of y'all
y'all are disgraceful to this country
and we're gonna come after of you
demonic your Devils we get saved right
are you guys Brothers yeah so
um if I told you guys that's a joke
that's the those are Comedians and they
troll Trump rallies that was satire who
would say no David that doesn't make
sense you would say that makes perfect
sense that makes more sense than that
these guys really exist as such here's
another guy at the Trump rally saying
that January 6th was antifa are we
supposed to believe that they didn't set
up the protesters on January 6th right
that's I mean that's exactly right
there's video out there that they're
trying to suppress that's all on
people's tick tocks and stuff where they
had antifa members inside the White
House on that day saying we need more
people we need more people now why would
there be antifa at the White House when
Trump was President does that does that
make any sense
yeah why they were trying to break oh
okay no so now the other guy corrects
him and goes do you mean the capital the
floor in one of the offices the lady was
in the window with a megaphone telling
people what to do and where to go yeah
there's so many holes in the official
narrative about January 6. right it's
just not none of it really makes sense
and of course like why would antifa try
to
keep Trump in office and prevent Biden
from being sworn in they they never have
an answer to that and lastly here's a
couple guys who have spent 30 grand
going to Trump rallies they cost you
guys to drive across the country I'm
just curious like how much of your own
and money you know obviously your own
money that you've invested to do this so
this is my 45th Trump rally I probably
invested thirty thousand dollars of my
own money coming here but by the way
invested
uh not exactly financial literacy you
know you're really burning the money
you're not investing it I would look at
index funds uh and maybe a little bit of
money in a high yield savings account if
you're actually looking for Investments
I I don't know that going to Trump
rallies really counts as an investment I
can tell you in the last year it's it's
been worse it's been worse the flights
are double the rental cars are double
gas is almost four dollars a gallon all
along the east coast it's it's getting
ridiculous you know I want it back to we
want it back to two dollar gas we want
it back to 100 flights and we want it
back to cheap rental cars well I don't
know if that's gonna happen because
things do get more expensive over time
but any one of these could be a joke any
one of these could be a skit
on Saturday Night Live Without A Doubt
and it would be
it would be more funny
if this wasn't a political movement with
teeth
that might get people as crazy as
Herschel Walker elected so that we've
now looked at the wacky from the weekend
but I am going to have to read everybody
the riot act I apologize in the next
segment because uh as wacky as some of
the the supporters are and as wacky as
some of the candidates are
some of them are leading in polls and it
is a dystopian nightmare that's coming
up after the break make sure you're
following us on Facebook at facebook.com
davidpackman show
us on social media interact with the
David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
so we're getting our first sort of
serious signal that this could be a
really ugly midterm election for
Democrats and it comes from none other
than the Georgia Senate race where
former NFL football player Herschel
Walker who we've covered quite a bit I
mean he's one of the least qualified
people running for Senate right now is
leading the incumbent Democratic senator
Rafael Warnock we're going to look at
polling and it would be funny
if it weren't so sad and scary so new
Emerson College poll
Georgia Walker versus Warnock Walker
leading 49-45 with six percent undecided
now of course there's a three percent
margin of error either way and six
percent undecided so that this could go
either way
but these are not good numbers and this
is not the only poll that has it this
way if we look at the real clear
politics page where you could see a
number of the recent polls you see that
Walker is leading by an average of 1.6
he's plus four in the Emerson poll I
just mentioned Walker is plus one in the
recent Quinnipiac poll Walker is plus
three in the AJC poll
and then back in August of last year in
the Democratic leaning poll Raphael
Warnock was ahead so we don't have that
much polling but none of it looks
particularly good for Raphael Warnock
and this should genuinely scare us this
is this is one of the most uninformed
people that is running for prominent
office Raphael Warnock for whatever you
may like or dislike about him
particularly as the incumbent to see him
doing this poorly is very bad remember
that we've talked about recently Raphael
I'm sorry uh Herschel Walker not Raphael
Warnock said
if evolution is real why are there still
Apes remember this brilliant analysis
here that means somebody up there had to
say let there be light that the earth
started and then he had to put someone
there on Earth remember Adam was there
remember Adam came there then Eve came
so somebody had to start it out
so that means it had to be a God because
it needed some bomb blew up and it
started out and then I'll tell you
something else I heard and I think about
this because at one time the sign said
man came from AIDS right did it not
every time I read or hear that I think
to myself you just didn't read the same
Bible I did well what this was
interesting though if that is true why
are there still Apes
think about it you know now you're
getting too smart for it no no no think
about this we have an evolution that is
we've gotten so intelligent that if that
is true why are there still Apes right
now of course we've talked about this so
many times before well modern apes and
modern humans have a shared ancestor a
really long time ago and if they're if
dogs evolved from wolves why are there
still wolves and yeah I mean it doesn't
make any sense but this guy's winning
this guy's winning and with this is what
we're up against and the voters hear
that and they go that's better than
Raphael Warnock
that's a real problem that's a real
problem here's another one of Herschel
Walker at a recent Trump rally I think
this one was about two two weeks ago
saying that he's sick of CTR
L whoa that's crazy
CTR open this contract people want to
ask me all the time while I'm running
I'm sick and tired I'm sick and tired I
didn't want to teach CTR in school
critical race Theory can you tell me
what that mean yeah well let's start
getting the acronym correct which is of
course CRT this is the guy that's
winning this is the guy that might
replace Rafael Warnock in the Senate so
it's it's very difficult you know in
general
elections aren't isolated and what I
mean by that is if there's a bunch of
incumbents if there's one incumbent
knocked out there will probably be a
bunch of incumbents knocked out but if I
think of a sort of Bellwether
representation of the midterms if you
see the uh incumbent Raphael Warnock
lose to a guy who can barely string
together a coherent thought and again if
he has a brain injury from playing
football okay I mean it's not been
announced that he does maybe it's
possible but it's it's it's dubious
whether the guy even kind of has his
head on straight
um if if Rafael Warnock loses to this
guy
it is really going to be a bad sign for
what uh the midterms have in store and
it's probably a bad sign for 2024. it's
probably a bad sign for Joe Biden in
general in his second two years of his
presidency never underestimate the
stupidity of the electorate that's what
we learned from Trump in 2016 when I I
was part of it saying
the country wouldn't be so dumb as to
vote the Republicans wouldn't be so
dumbest to make this guy their dominant
nominee right and they were
and then well the country wouldn't be so
dumb as to make this guy the oh oh and
they did this is a red alert emergency
it could be disastrous for Democrats it
could be disastrous for the country and
those polls look terrible
um one of the problems that Mehmet Oz is
facing in his uh Pennsylvania
um Senate candidacy is that he's running
as a Republican and yet he's been
pro-choice as far as I can remember for
a really long time maybe that's changed
he previously supported Obamacare he
previously supported health insurance
mandates before turning against them and
so there were some Maga people
who were not super big on Mehmet Oz and
now Trump has endorsed Mehmet Oz and
it's all going completely and totally
Bonkers Maga World melting down melting
down over Trump endorsing Mehmet Oz so
let's go first to the clip of Trump's
endorsement this was we looked at it
earlier in the context of the rally here
is Trump announcing to the crowd he
supports Mehmet Oz
by the way I endorsed another person
today Dr Oz in Pennsylvania Dr Oz
great guy a good man's good man Harvard
educated tremendous tremendous career
and they liked him for a long time
that's like a poll you know when you're
in television for 18 years that's like a
poll that means people like you but he's
a he's a great guy
this you know what's crazy
the reasons
that they dislike Mehmet Oz are pretty
reasonable things like he has a history
of being pro-choice he has a history of
supporting Obamacare that is making them
lose their minds over Trump's
endorsement of Oz the things that should
disqualify him immediately like the fact
that he promoted quack cures for colds
drinkable silver you know it's
indistinguishable from Alex Jones they
don't seem to have any problem with that
but magoworld is melting down Sean
Parnell the former Trump endorsed
candidate who had to drop out of the
race after an allegation surfaced uh
from his ex-wife wrote on Twitter
I have enormous respect for president
Trump
I was honored to have his endorsement in
Pennsylvania twice but I'm disappointed
by this Oz is the antithesis of
everything that made Trump the best
president of my lifetime he's the
farthest thing from America First and
he'd be very bad for Pennsylvania right
wing radio host Eric Erickson tweeted
it's like Donald Trump's staff is
sabotaging Trump by convincing him to
make the worst possible endorsements
Breitbart news's Joel Pollock wrote this
endorsement could divide Maga in the
only way that matters he could lose
America First conservatives over it and
then Republican Mo Brooks from Alabama
who's running for Senate he recently had
a rift with Trump trump unendorsed him
he wrote this is happening because Trump
surrounded himself by staff who are on
McConnell's payroll and hostile to the
Maga agenda everybody telling Trump who
to endorse in primaries were works for
the swamp they played him again Roger
Stone was on telegram writing wait
president Trump endorsed this guy Town
Hall columnist Kurt schlichter wrote
it's pretty hard for me to fully Express
how disappointed I am in Trump for
endorsing Oz from Blaze TV Ali Beth
Stuckey wrote wait is there anything
conservative about Dr Oz so they don't
love Trump they love what they imagined
Trump to be
and when Trump shows what he is which is
he puts his finger to the wind he
supports people he thinks will win he
supports celebrities he loves
celebrities that's what listen what's
the similarity between Herschel Walker
and Mehmet Oz there's not much
other than they're both well known in
Celebrity space sports TV Etc uh Trump
gets his information from TV
we should be glad he didn't try
nominating Judge Judy to the Supreme
Court because that's how Trump makes
decisions the real question is should
Oprah be held accountable for unleashing
Mehmet Oz upon the world I'm half joking
but it's horrible the guy's horrible
Herschel Walker's horrible Mehmet Oz is
horrible but if there's anything good
from this it would be hopefully the
division within Maga world over Trump's
endorsement of um of a Mehmet Oz we have
a voicemail number that number is 2192
David P you know I wonder
do the does my audience call other shows
to complain about me because so many of
our callers call me to complain about
other people the San Antonio troll
regularly complains to me about things I
didn't say that he heard on other shows
Troy York regularly calls in to complain
about other people and that's what he
did unleashing a brutal and completely
unintelligible attack on Kyle kolinsky
of secular talk I don't know what Troy's
talking about and I don't know why he's
calling me about Kyle see if you can
make any heads or tails out of this or
figure out how this even has anything to
do with me uh David
um Kyle Kolinski is a propagandist and a
liar
who keeps uh attacking companies that
are resisting unionization and Starbucks
and Amazon two examples okay
our companies that would not exist
through massive unionization
and this is the goal of Kyle Kolinski he
wants to see
Starbucks destroyed
more empty storefronts and communities
across this country
I mean listen quite Frank I haven't been
to Starbucks in 20 years I quite frankly
think the coffee is a disaster so I I
I'm half kidding I understand the jobs
component but uh I'm no big Starbucks
fan maybe Kyle shares in that I don't
know
um he attacks Amazon
despite the great services and products
that it's able to deliver okay
and Kyle Kolinski is basically a
undemocrat ignorance socialist a on
Democrat ignorant socialist
and I don't know how you ignorant
leftist by Kyle kolinsky
continue to lie in propagandize on the
internet
Kyle kulinsky I guess the same way Troy
does I don't know like yourself and Jake
ooger
and Sam Cedar
also what's playing in the background
but it's like my show is always playing
in the background of these calls
I hate this country our anti-American
you say nothing about no one not one of
this
unionization attempts against Starbucks
and Amazon
ever complaining about the workers and
taquerias
that are mostly funded by drug cartels
in Mexico
immigrant business you never talked
about
immigrant business and Indian
restaurants being unionization
yeah I mean uh I don't know what Troy
York is talking about and I don't know
why he's calling me about Kyle kolinsky
and I don't know what Kyle said but
please call Kyle I mean it is it why do
you have to call me just call Kyle tell
them what you think and uh I don't know
man it's a it's very very strange to
call me we're going to have a great
bonus show for you today we knew that
vehicle fatalities were up during the
pandemic but we didn't know why
we now know that excessive speed due to
less busy roads played a role in that we
are going to talk about wind and solar
which now are responsible for 10 of
global energy production that's still
not a massive number but it's a big
change and things are going in the right
direction there we are also going to
talk about another one of the problems
that has to be dealt with for long-term
space travel for humans you know in the
past we've talked about the radiation
component needs to be figured out a lot
of radiation when you travel through
space the other issue is bone loss and
there's a new study about it I want to
talk a little bit about cycling and some
things that are connected between those
things uh and a lot of uh energy now
going into
how do we deal with the bone loss issue
and that's something that's already
being studied very very interesting
stuff an Eclectic bonus show for you
today you can sign up and get instant
access at joinpakman.com the coupon code
wow 22 will save you a bundle and I
really look forward to seeing you on the
bonus show last reminder
for today I'll remind you again but next
Tuesday April 19th we will be doing a
live viewer Town Hall at 6 PM eastern
time it will be open to everybody
members will have their own way of
getting in touch with me during the town
hall and
um it's going to be streaming only on
our second YouTube channel the Pac-Man
Live YouTube channel so make sure you're
subscribed there it's free it's free to
subscribe it's free to watch it's
everybody can call in but if you want
priority handling during the time Town
Hall become a member at joinpakman.com
I'll see everybody on the bonus show and
then back here tomorrow